une réaction qui on reviendra évidemment
avec des questions avec nos invités en
plateau c'est celle de julien odoul
candidat du rassemblement national à
sens il est conseiller régional
rassemblement national vous voyez qu'il
arrive en troisième position je vous
propose d'entendre sa rédaction
sa réaction il est évidemment déçu c'est
un waterloo démocratique visiblement
mais ma sens puisque seuls 35 % de
l'électorat s'est déplacé c'est
extrêmement faible c'est à dire qu'un
peu plus de cinq mille électeurs ont
fait le choix de se déplacer pour élire
leur maire donc pour une ville de 25
mille habitants je considère que c'est
extrêmement préoccupant et ça illustre
bien la crise sanitaire l'ampleur
aujourd'hui de de cette épidémie
coronavirus qui inquiète énormément les
français